the Department of Justice has announced
a special counsel to investigate and
potentially bring criminal charges
against failed former president Donald
Trump indictment seems imminent
according even to many right-wing legal
Scholars even Trump's lawyers reportedly
are preparing for an indictment Trump is
losing his mind over this and we'll get
to that in a moment what is it that is
going to take place here well CNN
reporting doj announces special counsel
for trump-related Mar-A-Lago and January
6 criminal investigations multiple
criminal investigations at this time
Merritt Garland the Attorney General
appointed a special counsel to oversee
these investigations both investigations
implicate the conduct of trump who is
now a presidential candidate Garland
said based on recent developments
including Trump's announcement that he's
a candidate for president and the
sitting president stated intention to be
a candidate as well I have concluded it
is in the public interest to appoint a
special counsel that special counsel is
going to be a guy named Jack Smith
Jack Smith is the former Chief
prosecutor for the special Court in The
Hague where he investigated war crimes
in Kosovo Smith quote has built the
reputation as an impartial and
determined prosecutor that is absolutely
correct and these right-wingers and
trumpists have wasted no time in going
right into the character assassination
that we should expect about Jack Smith I
don't even want to devote time to that
right now if it becomes a bigger part of
the story and maybe it will because all
these people have his character
assassination maybe we will talk a
little bit more about Jack Smith Jack
Smith's appointment and his selection is
completely uncontroversial it is he's
just a normal
uncontroversial prosecutor okay so what
is it that is going to happen here
continued CNN article according to
multiple sources both the Mar-A-Lago
investigation and the January 6th
investigation around Trump are aiming to
gather more information and bring
Witnesses into a Federal grand jury in
the coming weeks
this is a really big deal
I know that many of you like me have
become desensitized to this because
everything about this failed former
presidency has been so unusual and so
out of what is typical but this is
really not normal we grand juries for
multiple potential crimes committed by a
former president who lost after one term
tried to stay in office despite losing
and is now running again potentially
because he thinks it will help him avoid
these investigations which Merit Garland
says it will not
some of the witnesses being pursued in
this round had not spoken to the
investigators in cases before many in
Trump's orbit believed in hoped the
investigation was slowed or halted
because they hadn't heard from the
justice department for weeks well okay
that isn't going to go on so there's two
views of this decision now if we zoom
out officially the decision is clear
Merit Garland was hired by Joe Biden Joe
Biden has stated his intention to run
for re-election the target of this
investigation is Donald Trump Donald
Trump has now said he's running for for
not re-election but for another election
and as a result Garland's boss could
potentially face off against the guy
he's investigating in order to remove
himself from possible allegations of
political bias here Merit Garland has
done the obvious thing which is to
appoint a special counsel to say you
come in and figure this all out I we
won't get involved in the charging
decisions now there's two views on this
one View
and I heard it from a couple of you is
that Merit Garland is a coward Merritt
Garland is afraid to actually do the
thing that many prosecutors seem to be
afraid to do which is to charge Donald
Trump we saw this in New York we saw the
South elsewhere they are afraid to be
the first to say all right you know what
the evidence is there
the standards have been met
I'm going to be the first to charge a
former president that's one perspective
and there is no doubt that there are
many prosecutors extraordinarily
hesitant and you could argue scared to
charge a former president I concede that
the second view is that Garland is smart
to distance himself from this ultimate
decision that it's predictable that
because Trump announced this campaign
you really just can't have I mean think
of the counter counter uh point to this
which would be Trump says I am now a
candidate
he's campaigning
and Joe Biden's attorney general is
investigating Trump
Fox News wouldn't let that fly as much
as they seem to be distancing from Trump
right-wing media if Republicans wouldn't
let that fly
so whether or not you think Garland is a
coward and he may be I mean it's I'm not
weighing in on that it's neither here
nor there
I don't think Garland had any choice he
can't actively be
in an Administration that could be
running against Trump and investigating
trump it just doesn't look good now when
you zoom out a little further there are
a number of legal experts who have
looked at this and said you this is
what's going on this is speculation but
there's a lot of consensus behind it
Garland probably realizes at this point
the evidence against Trump is so strong
he's going to end up getting charged one
way or another either for the stolen
documents or for something related to
January 6th
and Garland
needs to be able to as quickly as
possible separate himself from the line
prosecutors and the final steps of that
investigation and I believe that it is
accurate that he should be doing that
but many are also seeing this and saying
this also suggests the indictment is
imminent obviously if that indictment
comes we will have it for you let's now
look at Donald Trump's reaction to this
I love cooking at home I cook all the
time having a good set of knives that
you actually like to use is really
important for years I have been a fan of
the advantages that Japanese knives
offer and our sponsor kamikodo makes
amazing Japanese steel kitchen knives
using the traditional techniques that
date back to the Edo period of Japan
kamikoto only uses steel from Japan each
blade takes years to craft and goes
through a rigorous 19-step inspection
process with a lifetime guarantee the
knives come in a beaut beautiful heavy
duty Ash wood box makes it a really
great gift easy to store as well on the
kamikota website you can see a map of
the Michelin star chefs all over the
world using kamikoto knives my kamikoto
knives at home have been performing
great for years you really just can't
beat the feel of a nice Japanese knife
perfectly balanced in your hand and
kamikoto is now running a big Black
Friday sale my audience gets an extra
fifty dollars off go to kamikodo.com
Pacman and use the code Pacman the link
is down below